こんにちははじめシャツをです皆さんとなっていますでしょうか
僕も多さにコロペットを飼っていました僕は土壌と
あるキッドコーン明日を買うと勝った方がありますよ
左子でした僕思ったんですけどもペットは飼い主さんがいない時いつも何をしているん
だろうと思いますでペットの動きとか行動とか
ちょっと検証していきたいと思っておりますって言って今ライト検証に協力して
くださいって言うことの万全神ひーまーすぷりんちゃんとプレッシャーデーをえええ
大来てくれたん
稲葉に入っちゃってをづらくで右端で今回こちらのバイイングチャートグレースちゃん
とペットはあいね子がいないときいったい彼らを裏でどのような行動としてはなんか
こう
飼い主が時代場所じゃない何か特別なことをしているかも知れませんっていうのを
ちょっとも僕は気になったので今回継承してこの部屋じゃないところに僕は言っても
のっ
二つの動きを観察していきたいとおもいますでは行こう
ハイテクでまず3つほどちょっといろいろやってみようと思うんですけども
まずは飼い主がいないぞーたい人がいない状態でペットはどんな行動をとっているのか
ちょっと整備プレーでマザー
検証していきましょう
が水辺られてもねぇん
動かないです
扉をずっと見てるのかなった
出てった扉をずっと観ていません
結構ぼーっとしてるんですね
雨ちゃったのかなバリンジャー完全見た目に出てます
パインちゃんわかるんですけどグレイス茶会ない
今のカメラの位置だとグレースちゃんがどこにいるかわかりませんので
米良位置を変えていきます
ん
グレースちゃんがこれで明治ようになりましたソファーの上で目がこの家を主だという
中にあっております
九州取った
ジェスチャーはダメ7でましたが寝てます
あなた通りばりんちゃんは扉をずっと見つめ奥レーサーが
そば米でごろん香盤通達さ
平和の1日のくっております愛というわけで退院しがいないときペットは
れていますヘアを頃があって暴れまわったりすると思ってたんですけどちょっとし
かアシカアシカ悪しき新車きた
ああああああ
大都会だと家を守る気持ちでチンな人物を追い払ってくれると思うので
いや実際に不審者として突入してみましょう
委員というわけで不審者の格好が出来ました僕は今から子も結構で飼い主がいない部屋
に入り込んでいいが後の何かを結んでいきますそれに彼らは反応できるかどうかが今回
ポイントですではチェンソースタート
行ってきます
ん
プー
んわー
うわぁああぁわぁ
ああああああ
持った
変化が起こってマスター
チーズで吠えられたのでヤバい人が来たかと思って多分
守ったんだと思います
次は何ですけどももし飼い主がいない部屋の中で
ことであるとも龍野ボーイズさんが遊びに来たら果たしてどういう反応するのか
ちょっと検証されていきたいとおもいますアンフィ特別なリングをちょっと準備したの
でその方でちょっと友達として今からこの家に入れてみようと思います果たしてパリン
ちゃんのグレッシャーどんな反応するのか見てみましょう
ん
ああああああああああああああああああん
ううううううっうぅううああああああ
なーるん
ああああああ
e 4 tjedna
入ってるけどいかがだったでしょうか
ペットと飼い主の方一途なが見えた結晶だと思います
3個3個とね本当に実は飼い主が留守にしてる間ペット出すはどんな行動をとっている
のでしょうか
ペットを飼ったことがある人なら誰もが一度は考えたことがある
ペットた詰まりながらのに筒状と飼い主との絆
描いた映画でございます映画テッドが8月11日の木曜日祝日に公開されます顎自社に
柄が全部見たんですけどもうすごい得るジェットの膝の実情というかずっと笑ってい
られる楽しいらになっております
ベッドを買った人は z を買ったことがない人もみんな楽しめる映画となっており
ますぜひ皆さん見に行ってみてください
じゃあ